y pasamos ahora a nuestra revista de
prensa dedicada en esta fecha a las
mujeres con un especial que ha realizado
el medio del país sobre aquellas mujeres
que han inspirado la lucha feminista en
América Latina para ello quien mejora de
que Marta Moya Marta Buenos días y
cuéntenos de qué se trata Buenos días
Ángela vamos a destacar este informe
especial que hace el medio el país que
titula las mujeres que abrieron camino
en América el país ha destacado a seis
figuras mujeres que de alguna manera
marcan la opinión pública mujeres
protagonistas del momento que vive la
región y que destacan a sí mismo a otra
referentes que tienen ellas mismas no
Son seis mujeres que hacen un pequeño
perfil de esa referentes empezamos con
la primera de estas mujeres que es la
periodista Argentina Leyla guerriero que
destaca como referente a su compatriota
la escritora María Elena walsh de quien
dice se la recuerda como una gran autora
de libros y canciones infantiles es
mucho más que eso pero recordarla si no
está mal ese rótulo inofensivo le
permitió inocular en muchos de nosotros
el virus de la libertad la segunda
persona que destaca el diario El País es
la vicepresidenta de Colombia Francia
Márquez que Asimismo destaca como
referente a las mujeres del cauca que es
la región a la que pertenece Y una de
las más castigadas por la violencia en
Colombia de ellas dice han sido mi
máximo referente y ejemplo y su ejemplo
me ha dado la fuerza necesaria para
atreverme a desafiar las estructuras más
patriarcales verticales racistas y
hegemónicas de mi país la tercera mujer
que destaca el diario El País es la
expresidenta de chile y la exalta
comisionada de los Derechos Humanos
Michelle bachelet que recuerda como su
referente a la doctora Eloísa Díaz la
primera médica en chile y en América
Latina de quién dice su historia no
Recuerda que no es fácil ser pionera la
sociedad siempre ha pedido
excepcionalidad a las mujeres para
conseguir lo que otros heredan desde
hace siglos es una carga
desproporcionada la cuarta mujer que
destaca el país es
activista brasileña por los Derechos
Humanos que recuerda como referente a su
madre una de las pioneras en la defensa
de la amazonía de las tierras indígenas
de quien dice tenerla en la línea de
frente ante la emergencia climática con
su ante lo que estamos viviendo Perdón
me da Esperanza con su fuerza y amor No
solo nos ayuda a soñar sino que está de
nuestro lado completando y transformando
nuestra realidades la quinta mujer que
destaca el diario El País es la
diplomática mexicana Alicia bárcena que
recuerda también como uno de sus iconos
y uno de sus referentes a la refundadora
del feminismo chileno Julieta
su pensamiento exhibe uno de los rasgos
irrefutables de los clásicos trasciende
generaciones y sus palabras resuenan con
fuerza en las voces de muchas de esas
Jóvenes rebeldes que hoy están en
nuestras calles para cambiar la vida Hoy
y la sexta mujer que destaca el diario
El País en este informe especial es la
física brasileña Marcia Barbosa que
homenajea a su par Elisa baggio cytovich
que también es científica de quien dice
me pareció irónico que en lugar de
admirar la determinación de esta
investigadora muchos científicos
intentaron frenar su carrera entonces
una mujer no podía atreverse a robar los
recursos de investigación de los hombres
Sabe qué es lo que más me gusta que este
es un reporte de mujeres hablando de
mujeres no hoy en un día que nos
reivindicamos Y esa recuperación del
discurso que nos pertenece con nuestros
derechos humanos Esa fue la parte en la
que exaltamos nuestros logros y nuestras
luchas pero ahora vamos
de las denuncias nos vamos a ir hasta
Oriente medio Porque grupos de
activistas de Irán y de Afganistán piden
que se establezca un aparheid de género
como un delito reflejado en el derecho
internacional y lo dice de Garden sí
Ángela tanto activistas y Defensores de
los Derechos Humanos en Irán y
Afganistán dicen que las leyes
internacionales actuales no capturan la
naturaleza de las políticas que rigen en
esos países y que al final degradan el
estatus de la mujer por ello han lanzado
una campaña entre las firmantes está por
ejemplo la Nobel de la paz iraní Siri
nevani o la primera vicepresidenta que
tuvo Afganistán
fausia cuffy y así como decenas de
activistas y abogados internacionales y
piden que esa definición actual de la
parheid no representa a mujeres en
Afganistán y en Irán Aunque el concepto
descriptivo sí lo haga no Por ello piden
que se establezca un aparhe de género y
que el derecho internacional
recoja este delito argumentan que bajo
el régimen del talibán las mujeres
tienen prohibidos derechos Como la
educación moverse a largas distancias
sin tener a un tutor varón o incluso
trabajar en el sector público los
firmantes de esta de este manifiesto de
esta campaña dicen que no que no
pretenden discriminar la cultura
musulmana sino abordar como las mujeres
están subyugadas y que no pertenecen a
ninguna sociedad sea cual sea su
religión pero es que es muy difícil
Marta cuando uno no puede existir ni
siquiera libremente en la calle algo que
para usted y para mí es tan natural y
vamos a terminar esta revista de prensa
de hoy pero no sin hacer un comentario
sobre el trabajo que se está haciendo
aquí en France 24 por los derechos de
las mujeres Si Ángela tenemos una
cobertura especial como venimos ya
reportando los informativos así como
nuestra página web allí en la web
nuestras compañeras y corresponsales han
realizado reportajes a lo largo de
América Latina en una serie que llamado
colectivas poderosas tenemos informes
informes desde México desde Guatemala
chile o Colombia y hablamos de
chelemeras que recuperan manglares de
mujeres mayas que tejen esa justicia
social de activistas que confrontan la
violencia obstétrica en chile o de
mujeres que alzan la voz después del
conflicto armado en Colombia como
decíamos la cobertura seguirá a lo largo
del día y vamos a reflejar las marchas y
otros eventos conmemorativos que tengan
alrededor del mundo también en nuestra
web y de la forma más digna posible
gracias a usted Marta gracias